so first of all i just want to thank
elon for coming uh hungry yes you didn't
even have dinner and we didn't even feed
you properly we're sorry to be a bit
late uh oh no i just came from the tesla
factory in fremont yes is it was
something wrong
there's always something you have to
like at any given point there's always
something wrong yes um because there's
just too many things going on yeah so um
i mean one of the trickiest things about
a car is that there's this there's
thousands of individual components the
thousands of unique components and even
if one of those things is missing you
can't make cars
yeah so i mean today's fiasco was
um i kid you not um we were missing
three dollar usb cable
okay so we cannot complete cars because
the whole line was stopped
yeah so essentially because
it's part of the wiring harness so you
can't put the interior in um without
this this cable
um and
so we could even make a whole bunch of
cars minus an interior which means that
you've got to come up in the yard the
resale value would be no good well
it can be done but it's it's then things
go out of sequence oh right right right
um and and uh it's way more um
it's it's way more innovative you can't
you don't have a music moving production
line you have to send people out to
hundreds of of cars that are sort of
sitting in the storage yard
and um
so we we uh and this happens to be a
particularly pernicious cable that's
kind of like routed under the carpet and
a difficult place
um
and it's literally three dollars um and
uh so
we we basically
had to send people throughout the bay
area to go and buy usb cables like like
literally radio shack you like like
fries fries fries oh that's bad you can
have a hard time getting a usb cable
right now fries oh report every one of
them that's good
um
and and so we're able to continue
production
and uh i don't know i don't believe the
anecdote but essentially the um the
supplier is in china
and we had plan a and plan b
and plan a was like the normal
supply chain process and
but what the supplier did was instead of
sending our
uh
parts
in their own package they grouped it
together with a bunch of other stuff
for other companies and sent that all
via some extremely slow boat
from china to la
and when it got to la the other stuff
didn't pass customs oh so they wouldn't
they wouldn't let our stuff through
because they put it in like a barrel of
fruit or something i don't know i don't
know what what they put it in yes
something that customs didn't like and
the paperwork wasn't in order or
whatever so it got stuck there for for
like a couple weeks yeah and then we had
plan b
it's like so so we called and said look
you've got to air freight some of these
cables because little cables
to us
um and we talked to their u.s subsidiary
and ordered order from the u.s
subsidiary who then communicated to
china but then because
uh this was another batch of of parts it
was kind of double the order
it exceeded the credit limit that we had
oh yeah you got it so it bounced off
their credit limit so they didn't ship
it fascinating so so so someone's losing
their job now this is
not right no no you shouldn't
you should fire anymore uh it's i mean
it's pretty farcical and um
anyway so
it's coming like tonight at 11 p.m or
something wow and these things are
happening like all the time this is an
unusual circumstance
yeah um that's that's like one example
but there's many things like that so
i guess i mean that's actually a really
good example because that kind of leads
into what i've always been fascinated by
a lot of what you're doing is well i
guess well i'll start with
how did you get into this i mean you
know in a car
into cars into taking over nasa into
we're not taking over nasa uh being a
contractor for for for nasa the record
yes
you're not taking over nasa they're an
independent organization the the but you
all are becoming a major uh uh provider
of services for nasa uh obviously uh
kind of internet payments and payments
generally i mean these are very three
completely different spaces i think a
lot of people would not take someone
seriously if they kind of had a business
plan in one of these right
that's right
oh yeah you take pick your time um what
was your
i mean did you always think you were
going to be doing this or
when did it dawn on you that that you
would try to revolutionize three
industries
well
um when i was in college
i didn't actually expect to do it so it
was not like this is some long fulfilled
expectation
but but when i was in in college i
thought about what were the areas that
would most affect the future of humanity
in my opinion
um and the three areas where the
internet sustainable energy and space
exploration particularly if humanity
becomes a multi-planet species you know
there's kind of like a pretty
substantial bifurcation in our sort of
future if we're either
out there among the stars on multiple
planets or if we're confined to earth
until some obviously eventual extinction
events yeah um not that i'm pessimistic
about life on earth i mean i think
things are likely to be good but even
more likely to be good yeah by far
yellowstone's due for an explosion every
hundred percent right exactly
is about that
yeah yeah
there's everything it's been 700 000
since right right but yeah yeah super
volcano for those of you who don't know
it would envelop that well yeah no
exactly i know exactly exactly so so we
read the same books like right now
absolutely um
i mean something bad is bound to happen
if you give if you give it enough time
and civilization has been around for
such a very short period of time that um
you know these these time scales seem
like very long but on a evolutionary
time scale they're very short yeah um
you know a million years on evolutionary
timescales was really not much um
and it's been around for four and a half
billion years
so
that's you know a very tiny tiny amount
of time really but for us that would be
i mean can you imagine if
if uh human civilization continued at
anything remotely like the current pace
of technology advancement for a million
years where would we be no i mean
i mean i think we're either extinct or
on a lot of planets yes we should
those are the two options but given that
i mean one that's that's kind of as epic
as one can think about things i mean
literally uh i mean how how did you make
that concrete how does that turn into
spacex tesla and and paypal
well
so i thought about those these things
kind of in the abstract um not not from
the expectation that i would actually
have careers in those arenas but
um but i wanted to be involved in at
least one of them um and at first i
thought the best bet was going to be
electric cars yeah and so the area that
i was studying was
advanced capacitors right so essentially
capacitors that have an energy density
um exceeding that of batteries because
they have a very high power density but
but low energy density
we have a lecture to that oh yeah yes no
we should do that
we'll get later but yeah
exactly um
so um
obviously if you could make a capacitor
that had anywhere near the energy
density of a battery and with this
incredibly high power density it's
quasi-infinite cycle and calendar life
then you would have an awesome solution
for energy storage in mobile
applications
um
so that i was going to sort of work on
that and try to leverage um
the equipment that was developed for
advanced chip making photonics uh to
create uh
uh ultra precise capacitors at sort of
at the moment and this is when you were
going to go into grad school yeah you
you had a brief stint at stanford that's
right for the phd in applied physics
applied physics material science right
this is what you were so even then you
were thinking of kind of trying to do
something in the space well
actually this was yeah this was to work
on energy storage solutions for electric
cars yeah um
and um and i'd actually worked at a
company in silicon valley called
pinnacle research which did advanced uh
capacitors there were they were um
electrolytic
capacitors sort of um and
uh but the problem and actually were
pretty good they had like the energy
density of a lead acid battery
which for a capacitor is that's a big
deal um but they used uh ruthenium
tantalum uh oxide and
i think at the time there was maybe like
one or two tons of ruthenium mine per
year so it's not a scalable solution
but
i thought there could be some solid
state solution like just like you know
said using chip making equipment that
was going to be the basic idea but it
was one of those things where
i wasn't sure if success was one of the
possible outcomes
um you know and
like you can't it's difficult to bound
that problem exactly and say okay
so you're saying i wasn't i felt like
this was a destined failure it's another
way to parse that sent but anyway so no
i didn't i didn't think it would would
fail but i wasn't sure that success was
a possibility okay
yes um
you know and generally
you want to embark on something it's
desirable to figure out if success is at
least one of the possibilities right
exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes um but but ideally you
want to try to
bracket it and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
yeah um and i wasn't quite sure if that
was the case um i mean i think success
on an academic level would have been
quite likely because you can publish
some useless paper and uh
most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect
sorry i mean that's we have how many php
papers are actually used by someone ever
um i mean no it's a good point
percentage-wise it's not it's not good
and um so
so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
uh you add some
leaves to the tree of knowledge yeah
okay um and and that leaf is nope it's
not possible
right
[Laughter]
that goes seven years a mile
so that what so that was one path and i
was prepared to do that but then the
internet was the error came along and i
was like okay the internet i'm pretty
sure success is one of the possible
outcomes and it seems like i could
either do it
do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen or i could participate
and help bullet in some fashion you know
put
you know
like i just couldn't stand the idea of
watching it happen yeah yeah so that
that's uh so i decided to put things on
hold uh and
start an internet company
and that that was kind of a
we we worked on internet
like publishing software maps and
directions yellow pages kind of things
and
we had as investors and um
customers the the media companies so
like new york times company the knight
rider this was just at the early stages
i mean this was like late 95 95 so it's
really early stages that's really out
the gate yeah yeah absolutely yeah
and so then we you know we
the the reason we worked with the media
companies because we needed to have
money like there was no advertising
money in 95 right right
in fact the idea of advertising internet
seemed like a ridiculous people
um
obviously not so ridiculous anymore but
at the time it was it seemed like a very
unlikely proposition um and a lot of the
media companies weren't even sure that
they should be online right like what's
the point of that and do you all think
that paypal was just going to be a you
know simple little you know internet way
to or do you think it was going to turn
into the major kind of transaction
processing engine that it is right now
um i didn't expect paypal's growth rate
to be what it was yeah so
and that actually created major problems
so we started paypal on university
avenue
after the first
month or so of the website being active
we had a hundred thousand customers
really that that wow i didn't realize it
yeah it was nutty wow
and how did it start how did people just
even know to use it and i mean obviously
both buyer and seller have to be
involved yeah um
well
the
we started off first by offering people
twenty dollars if they opened an account
um and twenty dollars if they referred
anyone oh um and then
we dropped it to ten dollars and then we
dropped it to five dollars as the
network got bigger and bigger the value
of the network itself exceeded any um
uh sort of carrot that we could offer
how much would you just spend with that
kind of 5 10 20 incentive to get that
critical mass going that was a fair
amount i think was probably
60 or 70 million dollars oh wow okay so
it was a substantial oh okay so we're
not talking peanuts here yeah this is
yeah it depends on your relatives yeah
it's a peanut to google yes no that's
right that's right
yes yes i mean like google's got 50
billion apple's got i don't know 150
billion some crazy amount of money
yeah yeah
so it's not an outland well yeah no
that's i didn't realize i didn't realize
that was so
500 million dollars so you know
that's point one percent of google's
that's true you're right that's
inexpensive relative to them to them
it's
pretty inexpensive that's right um
uh and and then we did it we just did a
bunch of things to decrease the friction
because and and and
it's just like bacteria in a petri dish
yeah
so
the
what you want to do is try to have
one
customer generate um you know that like
two customers yeah okay or something
like that maybe three customers ideally
and then you want that that to happen
really fast
um
and um you could probably
model it just like bacteria growth in a
in a petri dish and it'll just
expand very quickly until it hits the
side of the sides of the pantry dish
yeah slows down
um
and then after paypal then i mean to
some degree you know the especially us
in silicon valley we can understand the
internet we we know people i mean
paypal's obviously have a scale that um
you know is is noteworthy but then
spacex just seems really
you know
like
well what how did you decide that i'm
definitely going to do that and then
like what's the first thing that you do
like how do you even like go out like i
don't even know how to start trying to
make a rocket company
um well neither did i really um the
and in fact the first three launches
failed so it's not as though it was like
you know spot on it's like what did not
hit the bulls side but but even getting
the point that you're launching rockets
i don't even know how to like how do you
get there and
like what did you do on like one how did
you decide and then what did you do on
day one like who did you call or did you
write a plan did you start i i don't
even know actually i mean the origin of
paypal um is or other spacex is is that
um
uh i was trying to figure out why
uh that we've not sent any people to
mars because the obvious next step after
after apollo was to send people to mars
so
but but what in fact happened was that
we sent a few people to the moon and
then we didn't send anyone after that to
the moon or mars or anything
but if you'd ask people in 1969 what
would 2013 look like they would they
would have said there'll be a base on
the moon they would be we would at least
send some people to mars and maybe
there'd even be a base on mars it'd be
like orbiting space hotels
and there'd be all this awesome stuff in
space yeah and and that's what people
expected yeah um and if you said well
actually the united states in 2013 will
not be able to send anyone to orbit
but i'll tell you what will exist is
that there'll be this device in your in
your pocket that's like the size of it
smaller than a deck of cards that has
access to all the world's information
and you can talk to anyone on planet
earth yeah and even if you're like in
you know some remote village somewhere
as long as there's something called the
internet that wouldn't know what that
means of course
then you would you'd be able to
communicate to anyone instantly
and
have access to all of humanity's
knowledge is it like [ __ ] there's no
way that that's going to be right right
right
and yet we all have that and uh
and and space is not happening so
i try to figure out like what was the
deal here and this was a 2001. it was
just a friend of mine asked me what i'm
going to do after paypal
i said well you know i've always been
interested in space but i don't think
there's anything that an individual
could do in space because it's the
province of government it's usually a
large government
but i'm i'm curious as to when we're
going to send someone tomorrow so i went
to the nasa website try to figure out
like where's the place that tells you
that and i couldn't find that
so i thought well like either i'm like
bad looking at the website or they have
a terrible website because surely there
must be that should be a big date yeah
yeah like yeah this is this is the tree
on the front page and then i discovered
actually that uh nasa had no plans to
send people to mars and or even really
back to the moon yeah um
so so this was really disappointing i
thought well maybe
this is a question
of
uh
national will like have have
do we do we need to get people excited
about space again
and and try to get nasa a bigger budget
and then that then then we would send
people to mars
and and so i
i
started researching the area
um becoming more familiar with space
reading lots of books
and
came up with this idea to do so called
mars oasis which was to send
a small greenhouse
uh with seeds and dehydrated gel that
land upon landing hydrate the gel you
have green plants on a red background
and the public is uh the public responds
to precedence and superlatives yeah so
it's the first life on mars the furthest
that life's ever traveled and you'd have
this money shot of green plants on the
right background yeah so
that that that that seemed like it would
get people pretty excited
um
yeah so that that i i started getting
into this and and trying to figure out
okay well
can i afford to
build the spacecraft because i had some
money from ezreal to paypal
but had to fit within that budget and i
figured we had to do two missions
because
if we uh if we only do one and it failed
then it might have like the opposite
effect but you were willing to bet the
farm so to speak on this yeah well um
yeah i figured like i was willing to
spend half the money that i got from
paypal yeah with no expectation of
return right um
because i thought this was just
something that was pretty important and
uh
yeah i'm like it seems like you could
spend half the money on demand and
paypal on this and it'll be if that got
nasa a bigger budget and resulting in us
going to mars that would be a good
pretty good outcome and when your
friends came or your family came up to
you said look you know there's nations
that can't do this you know you're
you're a guy but you have some resources
what did you say or do or think
well so
um
i i had a lot of friends might try to
talk me out of
starting a rocket company because they
thought it was crazy and what friend of
mine made me watch a video if rock is
blowing up
[Laughter]
and you know there were just lots of
people thought it was a really crazy
idea and there was some people that had
tried to start rocket companies not
succeeded and they tried to talk me out
of it and um but the thing is that the
premise for talking out of it was well
we think you're going to lose the money
that you invest i was like well um that
was my expectation anyway so i don't
really mind if i lose
you know i mean that might but i mean
it's not
it's not like i was trying to figure out
the rank ordered best way to invest
money right on that basis
um
you know chose space right i felt like
that's
you know i thought wow you weren't
looking at like money money market bonds
triple a bonds rocket company you
weren't like do real estate yeah
you know uh
invest in shoemaking
and whoa space is the highest roi yeah
that's that is not what i thought it
wasn't the premise
i just thought that it was important
that humanity expand beyond earth and
we weren't doing that so maybe there was
something i could do to kind of spur
spur that on
and then
i
um i was able to compress the costs of
the spacecraft and everything down to a
relatively manageable number and i got
stuck on the rocket
the the u.s rockets were way too
expensive i ended up going to russia
flew to russia three times to negotiate
purchase of a an icbm that i tried to
buy two of the biggest icbms in the
russian fleet in 2001 and 2002.
um and actually negotiated i'll just let
that statement stand i'm not even gonna
um
i i mean that's uh and well
actually i actually have to like who did
you call like like
i mean i i i i
yellow pages yeah yeah go to the market
like i mean how does this
i mean i don't get too much in the way
but i am curious just this one
particular thing you are you decide at
some point you need to buy an icbm yeah
well actually at first i tried to buy
just a normal launch vehicle that they
used to launch satellites right those
are too expensive i i see i see um
the the boeing delta ii would have cost
65 million dollars each and so two would
have been 130 and then i was like whoa
okay that breaks my budget right there
yeah um
and and i try to negotiate with them and
that was not how much does an icbm go
for i'm curious what's the market rate
for one of those um
well
this was right after fall it might have
gone up yeah yeah it's gone up a lot
since right but in in 2001 it would have
been about 10 million dollars
each for so two would have been 20 and
then
um and then i thought i could get the
rest of the mission down to also around
10 per so so we'd have
a dual mission with like two identical
launches to an angle spacecraft and
um you know for like roughly 40
million dollars
and
so i thought that okay i can do that and
but you must have had some like you know
rocket scientists advising you at this
point i mean this sounds like you're a
siri i mean you were yeah yeah it
engaged a bunch of
circuit consultants right right and i
kind of started to get to get familiar
with the space industry
and um
but then after the third trip to russia
i i can't realize that i was actually
wrong about
that on my first premise that that there
was a lack of will in fact i think that
there's a tremendous amount of will in
the united states for uh space
exploration um because the united states
is essentially a nation of explorers i
mean it's a distillation of the human
spirit of exploration
so of course
um it was quite silly for me to think
that
that that people like motivation but
what people don't want to think is that
okay um
going sending people tomorrow is going
to be so expensive that they'll have to
give up like healthcare or something
right yeah they're not going to do that
um so it's got to be
it's got to be that going to mars is not
going to
cause some
meaningful
drop in their standard of living right
yeah so if it's like maybe
a quarter of a percent or half percent
of gdp something like that is palatable
right um
anyway so so
so i thought okay it's not really going
to maybe matter that much if i do this
mission because
what really matters is is having a
a so so i was wrong i i thought i
thought i thought there was it wasn't
enough will but there actually was
plenty of world if people thought there
was a way
so so then i said okay well i need to
work on the way
um
how hard is it really to make a rocket
in history historically all rockets have
been expensive so therefore in the
future all rockets will be extensive but
actually that's not true
if you say what is a rocket made of and
say okay it's made of
aluminum titanium some copper
carbon fiber if you want to go that
direction
and and you can break down and say what
is
what is the raw material cost of all
these components and if you have them
stacked on the floor and could wave
magic wand
so that the cost of rearranging the
atoms was zero um then what would the
cost of the rocket be yeah i was like
wow okay it's really small it's like
you know two percent of water costs
right so clearly the in how the atoms
are arranged right the the other so so
you got to figure out sort of okay how
can we
get the atoms in the right shape
um
much more
efficiently yeah and
um
so i had a series of meetings on
saturdays with people that were someone
who were still working at the big
aerospace companies just to try to
figure out is there some catch here that
i'm that i'm not appreciating and i
couldn't figure it doesn't seem to be
any catch so
started spacex and you and you ended up
bill i mean you had some failures but
obviously some huge successes what was
the cost that you were able to build
this rocket for relative to what they
were being built for before
so actually for the falcon 1 which is
the first rocket we built and the first
three flights did not make it in fact um
yeah i mean we got
it sort of progressively further but um
like the first rocket like came in
landed
maybe a couple hundred yards away from
the launch site and
you know tiny fragments
so
yeah anyway that that rocket ended up
costing
around six million dollars wow um
compared to other rockets in that class
which were
about say 25 million wow so significant
yeah like a quarter wow wow
and
but but there's an even better step
beyond that which is to make rockets
reusable yeah um so
right now our that is around around
what what our comparison price is
excluding the refurbished icbms so if
you say building rocket from new how
does the spacex rocket compared to
a rocket from boeing a lockheed it's
about a quarter of the price
[Music]
however if we make it reusable then it
can be 2 magnitude cheaper two orders of
magnitude cheaper well one hundredth the
price that's right so so i mean and two
and i've seen you
wait for volleyball only today
memorial day sale
what
and i've seen some y'all are doing like
these vertical landings yeah like
literally out of like the 1950s like
like sci-fi movies and that's what
you're talking about yeah yeah
essentially the rocket needs to come
back and land at the launch site and
then um reload propellant take off again
like an airplane and how far do you
think we are
from that like when do you think like
you know your best guess is when we'll
actually see that happening i'm hopeful
we can do it next year oh okay yeah
let's um we got we've got some ambitious
stuff that khan academy for the next
year too so we can
compare we're redesigning the site you
know
right
we've been working on it for a long time
i should say
spacex has been around for 11 years and
thus far we have not recovered any
rockets we've recovered the spacecraft
from orbit so that that that was great
um but none of our attempts to recover
the rocket stages have been successful
um the rocket stages have always blown
up basically on re-entry yeah
now we think we've we think we figured
out why that that was the case
um and it's a tricky thing because
earth's gravity is really quite strong
um and
with
uh advanced an advanced rocket you can
do maybe two to three percent of your
lift off mass to orbit
um
typically
and then reusability subtracts two to
three percent because you have to yeah
so then you go like nothing to orbit or
negative right and and
that's obviously helpful um
and
so the trick is to try to shift that
from
say two three percent
in an expendable configuration
put to make the rocket
um
mass efficiency engine's efficiency and
so forth so much better that it moves to
around maybe three and a half to four
percent in an expendable configuration
and then try to get clever about the
reusability elements and try to drop
that to
around the two one and a half to two
percent level so you have a net payload
to orbit of about two percent but you're
doing it at one two orders of magnitude
cheaper yeah absolutely because so
our falcon 9 rocket costs about 60
million dollars
but the propellant uh cost which is
mostly oxygen as two-thirds oxygen
one-third fuel
is only about two hundred thousand
dollars wow
um it's much like a
like a 747 costs about as much to
refuel our rocket as it does to refuel
747 you know within you know pretty
close essentially so what i mean if
assuming y'all are successful and you
all have proven yourself to be you know
successful on kind of these audacious
things in the past i mean what happens i
mean that seems like it's
and what happens the next five ten years
in the space industry if y'all are
successful there uh i mean do we get to
mars do we do we have kind of uh market
forces commercialization of space
starting to happen
yeah
um
let's see
well the first step is that we need to
earn enough money to keep going as a
company so we have to make sure that
we're launching satellites
uh you know
commercial satellites like
broadcast communications mapping
government satellites that do scientific
missions
uh earth-based
or space-based missions gps satellites
that kind of thing
and and then also servicing the space
station transferring cargo to and from
the space station which we've done a few
times
and and then taking people to and from
the space station
so so we've got a we've got a service
the
sort of needs
earth-based needs to approach satellites
and that that pays the bulls but
in doing that
keep improving the technology
to the point where
we can make full reusability work
and we have sufficient scale and
sophistication
to be able to take people to mars wow
so you think this is going to be a
reality and
what what's your best guess when we're
going to have someone on mars
i think probably about 12 years 12
and you think it'll be a round trip
it'll be yeah it'll just be some type of
permanent colony on on mars yeah i think
it's probably a round trip wow
so for for i mean it's not for sure i i
could i could talk about this for i mean
the people
yeah no this this this yeah this is
mind-blowing and i mean and then on
tesla i mean tesla's obviously i mean
from from our from my advantage huge
success i mean it's i mean what do you
think is in in that into well well one i
mean i'll ask kind of the same question
why did you think you you know this is
something that the gm and toyota and
these massive multi-billion dollar
organizations have been trying you know
what gave you the confidence to kind of
pursue it and now that it seems to be a
huge success where do you think this
industry is going to be in the next five
10 years
um yeah so with with tesla
the goal is to try to accelerate the
advent of sustainable transport
um i think it would happen anyway
because just out of necessity but
because we have an unpriced externality
in the cost of gasoline
um we were pricing in the environmental
effects of co2 in the ocean's atmosphere
that that's causing um
the normal market forces to not function
properly and so the goal of tesla is to
try to act as a catalyst to accelerate
um
those sort of normal forces that the
normal sort of market reaction that
would occur um
we're trying to have a catalytic effect
on that yeah
and
and try to make it happen
i don't know maybe 10 years sooner than
it would otherwise occur yeah that's
that's that's the goal of tesla so
that's the reason we're making electric
cars and not any other kind of car and
we also supply power trains to toyota
and to mercedes
and and maybe to other car companies in
the future
to
accelerate their um
production of electric vehicles so so
that's that's the sort of goal there and
so far it's you know working out pretty
well i mean i just saw a news report
earlier today that y'all are sold more
to model s's than uh you are leading
that segment of of the industry that the
mercedes s-class the bmw 7-series or the
the lexus
ls 400 or whatever it is
uh yeah actually that that seems to be
the case
and that's uh yeah i didn't realize they
sold so a few cars in that segment that
sounds
we don't sell that many cars right five
thousand a quarter you know well out
here they seem like you know everything
yeah i mean well this is our home yeah
yeah yeah
team you know um
so it's uh we met us all in the barriers
yeah yeah yeah yeah
no but that's and
what i mean similar thing i mean what
what how did you start what gave you the
confidence and and i mean do you do you
see yourselves i mean it's kind of a
major automotive mainstream brand in
five 10 years all the way down to kind
of the you know the competing with the
honda accords and civics
um yeah i mean i i mean a goal is not uh
it's not sort of to
become a big brand or to compete with
honda civics
but rather to advance the cause of
electric vehicles
so
we're just going to keep making
more and more electric cars and driving
the price point down until the industry
is very
firmly electric you know like
maybe half of all cars made or electric
or something like that which is not to
say that we expect to make we'll have
all cars we we want to just
have that catalytic effect until at
least that occurs and i think at the
point which there's you know we're
approaching half full new cause made are
electric then i think that's
i would consider that to be kind of the
victory condition wow um
and and so the faster we can bring that
day
the better uh
what would be your guess when that
happens
um well i made a bet with someone about
three years ago that it would be sooner
than 20 years so it's 17 years from now
but but that's
i think
that's
conservative i think it's probably
you know
maybe
maybe 13 or 14 years wow right right
about the time like right when we're
going to mars right it'll be
it'll be exciting exciting times yeah
absolutely true
it just could yeah exactly i was just
thinking about that it was like oh those
time k frames are kind of coincident
yeah um
yeah
i mean the nature of new technology
adoption is it tends to follow an s
curve so so what usually happens is
people underpredict it in the beginning
because people tend to extrapolate on a
straight line and and then they'll over
predict it kind of at the midpoint and
because there's late adopters right and
then you know
it'll actually take longer than people
think
at the mid point but much shorter than
people think at the beginning yeah yeah
um
and um yeah but i'm pretty excited about
how things going it's um
and in fact i think
i think that the pace of technology
improvement is in energy storage
electric electricity storage is is
really
moving faster than anyone thinks wow wow
i got one more what are we doing on time
where's after
or nine o'clock so how much time do you
have i want to make sure
i guess we have another 15 minutes oh
okay okay um so i'll finish with one
last question then we'll open it up i
mean what what advice do you have for us
um at khan academy um we're guessing
you're doing really great so yeah i
thought i was wondering if you had
advice for me oh no well
um
yeah i i i mean it seems like you're
doing doing doing an amazing job of real
really super leveraged you know i mean
obviously a small team and you're having
a dramatic effect on half these people
don't even work here
so like it's even yeah right it's right
so it's uh i think very impressive uh
thing you're doing um
to to spread
knowledge and and understanding you know
throughout the world the universe soon
if you hold up your end of the bargain
um yeah yeah yeah i mean it's actually
kind of funny like um you know if you
think like what is education like you're
basically downloading data and
algorithms into your brain
and
it's it's actually
amazingly
bad in conventional education because
like it shouldn't be like this huge
chore um
so you're making it way way better um
but i mean i think i think i think a lot
of things that i would say you've
probably heard a hundred times um
and an effect are if not doing like the
more you can gamify
the uh the process of learning the
better like
for my kids i do not have to encourage
them to play video games yeah okay i
have to like pry them from their hands
like like crack yes yes like drop that
crack needle yeah yeah
you have that problem at your house too
yeah the crack is addictive
so it's
you know it's it's it's to agree that
you can make uh somehow learning like a
game but that then it's better um
and i think unfortunately like a lot of
education is very bored billion um
you've got
uh you know someone's standing up there
kind of lecturing at people
and they've done the same lecture 20
years in a row and they're not very
excited about it and that lack of
enthusiasm you know is conveyed to the
students that they're not very excited
about it they don't know why they're
there like why are we learning this
stuff we don't even know why um in fact
i think a lot of things people learn
probably there's no point in learning
them um
because they never use them in the
future because who's going to launch a
rocket into space i mean that's just
like yeah exactly that never happens
um well you have to say like people i
think don't stand back and say well why
are we teaching people these things and
we should tell them probably why we're
teaching these things because a lot of
kids just in school kind of puzzled as
to why they're there
yeah
and i think if you can explain the why
of things
then that makes a huge difference to
people's motivation yeah then they
understand
they understand purpose yeah um
so i think that's pretty important
uh and just make it entertaining but i
think just in general like conventional
education should be massively overhauled
and i'm sure you very much agree with
that but yeah
so
it's i mean the analogy i i sometimes
use this like you've seen like batman
like like the chris nolan
movie like the recent one and it's
pretty freaking awesome right um
and you've got incredible special
effects great script uh multiple
takes amazing actors
and great sound and it's very it's very
engaging
um
but
if if you were to instead say okay that
even if you have the same scripts at
least it's the same script and you said
okay now that script instead of having
movies where we're going to have
that script performed by the local town
troop right okay and and so every in
every small town america if movies
didn't exist they would have to then
recreate
the dark knight right you know with like
home like home sewn costumes and like
you know jumping across the stage
and not not getting their lines quite
right and not really looking like you
know
the people in in in the movie
and and no special effects
i mean that would
[Laughter]
so with that and i apologize to all of
you guys for hugging up all the time
because obviously i could talk for hours
about this stuff but we do have time i
think five or ten minutes for for a
handful of questions um if none of you
all have any i have about nine more but
yes
um yeah so i noticed i picked up two
kind of themes from from what you were
discussing one was uh
somewhat audacious goals um and the
other was i don't think i heard you use
the word profit and anything that you
spoke about um
you seem to be each each thing is
pointed at like
reinvigorating an industry or bringing
back uh space missions how much of your
success do you attribute to having
really audacious goals or
versus
um just not being focused on the short
term
you know money coming in or
i know investors unfortunately i i i
when one does have to be focused on
the short term and money coming in when
creating a company because otherwise the
company will die
so the
the i think that a lot of times people
think
like creating companies
going to be fun i would say it's not
it's really not that fun i mean there
are periods of fun and there are periods
of where it's just awful um
and particularly if you're the ceo of
the company
um
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
um
there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right so you
only spend on things on your time on
things that are going wrong and and
there are things that are going wrong
that other people can't can't take care
of so you have like the worst you have a
filter for the crappest problem in the
company
the most pernicious and painful problem
um
so i wouldn't say it's it's i think you
have to feel quite compelled to do it
um
and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine
who who says like starting companies
like
staring into your bus and eating glass
and there's some truth to that
the staring into the best part is that
you're going to be constantly facing the
the
extermination of the company
because most startups fail
it's like 90 percent ugly 99 of of
startups fail
so
uh so you that that's the staring into
the abyss part you're constantly saying
okay
if if if i don't get this right the
company will die
um
it should be quite quite stressful and
and then
um
the eating last part is
you've got you've got to do
you've got to do the problems you're
going to you've got to work on the
problems that the company needs you to
work on not the problems you want to
work on
and
so that
that's you end up working on problems
that that
you'd really wish you weren't working on
and so that's the eating glass part
um
and that goes on for a long time so how
do you
keep your focus on the big picture when
you're constantly faced with we could be
out of business in a month
[Music]
well it's just a very small percentage
of mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know where
you're generally heading for
and and the actual path is going to be
some sort of zigzaggy thing in that
direction
um
you try not to deviate too far from the
path that that you want to be on but
you're going to have to do that to some
degree
but i don't want to i don't want to
diminish the i mean i think the product
the profit motive is is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's nothing fundamentally
wrong with profit in fact profit just
means that
uh people are paying you more for the
whatever you're doing then you're
spending to create it
that's a good thing
and if you're not if that's not the case
then you'll be out of business and
rightfully so
you're you're not adding enough value
now there are cases of course where
people
will do bad things in order to
achieve profit but but that's actually
quite unusual i mean because usually the
rules are set up mostly correctly like
not completely but mostly correctly
well i think we have time for one one
more question joel the same yeah i have
an important one okay very good yes
okay so a few months ago you teased
hyperloop
and we haven't heard anything since
um so first of all a few of us engineers
were talking about it i think we have a
few ideas if you need help
but
if you feel comfortable uh
maybe you could tell us a little bit
more uh i was reading about the
california high-speed rail
and it was quite depressing
because
california taxpayers are going to be on
the hook to
to build the
most expensive uh high-speed rail per
mile in the world and the slowest
which is
those are not the superlatives you want
[Laughter]
and and it's like damn it like we're in
california we make super high-tech stuff
why are we gonna be spending a hundred i
mean not now the estimates are around
100 billion dollars for
something that that will take
two hours to go from um la to san
francisco i'm like okay well i can get a
plane and do that in 45 minutes um
it doesn't make much sense
and isn't there some better way to do it
than that
so so
if if you just say okay well what would
you ideally want
in in a transportation system you'd say
okay well you'd want something that
relative to existing modes of
transportation
is
faster let's say twice as fast costs
half as much per ticket um can't crash
is immune to weather um
and is you know you can make the whole
thing like self-powering with like solar
panels or something like that that would
be pretty that would be that'd be good a
good yes
and so what what would do that
um and what's the fastest way short of
inventing teleportation that you could
do something like that
um and some of the
elements of that solution are fairly
obvious and some of it some of them are
not so obvious um
and then the details
um the devils in the details of actually
making something like that work
um but i came to the conclusion that
that there is something like that that
could work
um and would be practical
is this the around the evacuated tubes
the the vacuum tubes like the old banks
something like that yeah
but you haven't been more public with
what this is um
no although i did say that once tesla
was profitable that i would uh
talk more about it um but
we haven't done our earnings call yet so
i think i should probably do it yeah
after the earnings call um
and
the thing is like i i kind of strung out
on the things that i'm doing so adding
another thing yeah
just like doesn't you know that's
learning the guitar you could you could
pick up all sorts of things right i
tried learning the violin yeah that's by
the way a hard thing to learn
[Laughter]
launching rockets electric cars yeah
revolutionizing transportation
i cannot play the violin at all
very horrible
if you think about the future you want a
future that's better than the past and
and so if we had something like the
hyperloop i think that would be like
cool like you'd look forward to the day
that that was working
you know and and if something like that
even if it was only you're only
was in one place you know from l.a san
francisco or new york to
dc or something like that then
um
it would be cool enough that it would be
like a tourist attraction maybe like a
riot or something yeah
so even if
some of the initial assumptions didn't
work out the economics didn't didn't
work out quite as as one expected it
would be like cool enough like i want to
journey that place just to just to write
on that thing that would be pretty cool
um
and
so that's i think how if you cope with
the new technology it should feel like
that you should really
like if you told it to an objective
person would they look forward to the
day that that thing became available
yeah and like you know it'd be pretty
exciting to do something like that
um or an aircraft like i thought it was
really disappointing when that when the
concorde was taken out of commission and
there was no supersonic uh transport
available
um
and of course the 787 has had some
issues yeah
so
but it's but the thing is the 787 even
the best case scenario is only a
slightly better version of the triple
seven yeah um
and it's like okay
not that exciting so so they're they're
this is something that you are working
on
and and one day in the not too far
future or there's some plans or
consultants involved or something
um
you made some phone calls to russia um
every now and then like there's like
it's sort of percolating away and then
i'm i'm not actively thinking about it
but then there'll be some new element of
that i'll think oh well you know this
would make it better fascinating um yeah
no well
i mean i think i'm speaking for everyone
this is like the most epic possible
conversation one could have over about
the course of an hour and i think all of
us would love to chat with you for hours
on end but thank you so much i mean i
know you have a lot of free time so it
probably wasn't that big of a deal for
you to come here uh but yeah it was a
huge honor and i think it's inspired all
of us to go out and change the world and
the universe cool
thank you very much